welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka commissioner
boredom and this week we have some
brand-new updates on the supporting cast
of the Batman every week
same bat-time same bat-channel we break
down all of the new updates on the movie
and as always there's a lot to unpack
throughout this video we'll be
discussing the look that they're going
with the Commissioner Gordon the
potential Firefly and Riddler bodyguard
casting news as well as Peter Sarsgaard
comments on his character we're also
gonna be debunking the rumors that
Johnny Depp is going to be starring as
the Joker so yeah there's a lot to talk
about there may be some spoilers here so
if you want to go into the film as blind
as possible then I highly suggest that
you turn off now make sure you subscribe
to the channel to never miss a video
and please drop a like if you've been
enjoying the coverage so far without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of the
Batman updates
okay so firstly we have two big casting
announcements this week that the
internet is currently going wild over
firstly is Eliot Warren this fired up
the internet and sent everyone into a
meltdown with many believing that the
actor would end up becoming the Batman
villain Firefly there have been several
reports over the last year that have
stated the character will be making his
big film debut in the movie next year
and these rumors were first circulated
by cinema blend in 2019 the rumors were
given further precedents when Vick
Waghorn was cast as a Gotham fire chief
the word fire coupled with the rumors
lined up things a lot for fans and then
the casting of Warren's seemingly gave
things a lot more weight whilst we don't
know for definite and I'm still a bit
unsure and whether this will be the case
I can certainly see him fitting the role
should the villain actually be in the
film Warren has a very unique look to
him and the actor has starred in
stick-up Christmas Carol and a couple
more films no one is expecting Firefly
to be a big part but rather someone that
adds some texture to Gotham and I think
they would go with an up-and-comer like
Warren to fit this role again this is
all speculation so take it with a grain
of salt but I'm just reporting the
general consensus on the internet right
now in addition to this actor mark
Killeen was also recently cast in the
film now we're kind of joining the dots
here a bit but there
was a casting call a while back that
wanted a male between 20 and 40 to play
a minion for the character codenamed the
brain now he don't have to be the brain
to figure out that this character is the
Riddler and Kelleen definitely fits the
demographic that they're on the lookout
for because of this many have speculated
that he will be a minion henchman or
bodyguard of the Riddler though the
Riddler poses a difficult challenge to
Batman mentally he's never been a
physical fighter and thus he has to
enlist henchmen for his protection
Kaleem provides this and Batman always
needs people to punch in the face so I
don't see why he can't be the one to
take a bat beating as I've said we are
just kind of joining the dots right now
and now I'm still a bit unsure on the
firefly casting of Warren I do think
that Killeen will be fitting this part
now you may have seen some rumors
circulating that Johnny Depp is in talks
to play the Joker in the film there have
been tons of fan art mock-ups and
earlier this week one by boss logic
broke the internet everyone was crying
out for Depp to be cast as the Clown
Prince of Crime however the only outlet
that actually seems to be reporting that
this is true is we got this covered
which tends to be a red flag chances are
you're aware that the website is pretty
much all rumors and clickbait and with
this being the only source of the story
it seems highly unlikely that it's true
if you compare this to the other casting
news of Robert Pattinson and Jeffrey
Wright both were dropped on the internet
before they were officially announced
however these reports came from places
like The Hollywood Reporter and variety
whereas with this there's been solely
from we got this covered and no one else
has picked up on it Depp is just about
to start legal procedures with his
ex-wife who also just so happens to work
with DC I think if you use your common
sense
you'll realize that the studio probably
won't want to be swept up in the
negativity of the pair that is likely
incoming a lot of dirty laundry is about
to be aired so it doesn't make sense to
cast the two actors that are caught up
in it even if it would be justice for JD
warner bros have just recently recast
the Joker and I can't see them wanting
to do it for a third time in less than a
decade though Phoenix's Joker may be
completely separate to patterson's it
just doesn't make sense for casting
rumors to start this early Phoenix has
just won the Oscar for Best Actor
really can't see the studio wanting to
recast them so soon especially after
this acclaim so yeah everyone just
approach these stories with some
scrutiny as they're built purely to be
sensational and drive clicks to websites
I'll keep you right don't worry I'm the
Boy Wonder and people wonder how I've
got so many subscribers it's cuz I'm
great now onto some more positive news
we have our first look at what
Commissioner Gordon will look like in
the film Jeffrey Wright was recently
pictured with a moustache that is in
line with all of the iterations of the
character well ever
whether it's your 1989 version the Nolan
one or any page in a comic featuring
Gotham PDS best man the character always
done the stache and it's great to see
him going with the look - I've been
binge-watching Westworld to get back up
to speed with everything before the
series returns on Sunday and boom
heartache and all I think that Jeffrey
Wright is gonna be incredible
I know it's a bit of a heartache but I
just thought I'd drop that in anyway
hopefully we get a full look at the
actor and costume soon as I'm loving
these little bits of info dropping on
the movie now before we get into the
rest of the video I just wanna let you
know we're giving away a free copy of
the Infinity Saga box set to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be and
when the chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the updates in the
comment section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of March
in the set will be shipped out from the
intro ever gets the prize it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part okay
so if you've been keeping up to date
with the channel then you'll know that
last video we broke down a post about
how the production was moving to st.
George's Hall in Liverpool we theorize
that this could be the Batcave or part
of the city in which Batman can store
his stuff and park the car this has been
given a lot more way to with passers-by
taking photographs of the location and
we can see that there is an area for a
car to go into the subsection of the
building
this would allow Batman to have the car
in the cave and it would add a lot more
authenticity to the set where the
filming is going ahead is still up in
the air right now as well due to that
other thing that is up in the air right
now that we can't mention because
YouTube's demonetized videos on it but
it really does seem like a fit location
for it Matt Reeves has been releasing
official images of things before we've
seen them publicly this was the case
with the Batsuit which was revealed
before the bat bikes
so it makes sense that with the
batmobile reveal last week that it could
be at this location I'd love to see the
Batmobile speeding in and out of the
area and I can't wait to see it tearing
through the streets of the city and
finally we have an interview with Peter
Sarsgaard who appeared on The Late Show
questions quickly went to the Batman and
SARS guards started to discuss his
character I'm gonna play the clip in
just a bit but it does point out what
the state of Gotham could be like this
is a new characters a new character
created for the movie right called Gil
yeah yeah y'all wholesome yeah yeah okay
and I'm a district attorney and I'm
basically a a politician that has
trouble telling the truth for the people
out there who may not remember your
lovely wife Maggie Gyllenhaal was also
in the The Dark Knight she was okay now
do your children your children have to
choose which non Batman character from a
Batman movie they love more are they
prepared are you gonna put the screws to
the kids
I mean hers is so lovely her character I
mean I know a really distasteful person
and yet daddy doesn't play nice people
you know typically typically let's be
honest the guy in this is not very nice
no but okay so as skarsgård says the
character isn't a very nice guy to be in
such a position of power and gotham
shows that corruption is rampant
throughout the city and that is why
there is probably the need for a batman
what's interesting is that Sarsgaard is
playing the DA and if we are going off
Batman law then the character is likely
going to be killed at some point so that
Harvey Dent aka two-face can take up the
position dent is another person that is
rumored to be in the film so it's likely
that saws God will get his comeuppance
at some point in the movie and leave the
position vacant for either someone in
this film or someone to arrive in
sequels I did say in our last video that
I feel like Dent will be in the movie
but in a different form to what we've
seen before
I definitely recommend that you check
that out after this if you want to see
our thought process and the theories on
why this is the case overall as a ton of
things to look forward to and well
these updates bit by bit are okay I
think they come together to make some
interesting news that provides us with a
lot of big things to look forward to the
tone and style of the movie is really
starting to gain its foundation and I
can't wait to see what's right around
the corner next week could be a busy one
here at the channel with more outdoor
filming due to comments and hopefully we
get our first look at the Batmobile in
motion obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these updates and what you
want to see in the next couple of weeks
as mentioned earlier we do break downs
on the Batman every week same bat-time
same bat-channel
or whenever we decide to upload it so
make sure you stay locked to never miss
any of the information if you enjoy this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and check out our full breakdown of the
Batcave and our theory on Harvey Dent
which is going to be linked at the end
if you want to support the channel from
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below you
get access to content early and can
suggest video topics and breakdowns we
massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to helping videos like this get
made if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below those are
the best ways to keep up to date with
heavy spoilers so hopefully we see over
there very soon this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]